the studio host for football night in
America and like the our two guests in
Chris Fowler a man who was at the
wedding of me and Sue's back in the day
and somebody who's up who's warm embrace
I was appreciated appreciative of being
in when he called the Notre Dame
Michigan game on NBC a couple weeks ago
he's Mike Tirico here in the program how
are you Mike I wrote are you folks
miller named Wahby hi guys are you in
the day or you were in the Notre Dame
lobby right now we're just I'm just
walking out of the football office they
play Vanderbilt this week so we just
finished our music okay so Michigan was
the warm-up for Vanderbilt game is what
you're saying
Michigan Ball State Vanderbilt in that
order that back back to back to back
alright so how real do you think Notre
Dame is Mike really good I think that
chance to be one of the teams in the
conversation because of their schedule
as the year goes on they're gonna play
good team so they'll have opportunities
you know Richard when I was at the big
picture this year I think you have the
routines that we know all about brand
names like the Alabama's and the
Georgia's Ohio State and I think after
that it's going to be interesting to see
what the next tier of teams at Clemson
excuse me the next tier teams is going
to be there's no name have a dynamic
offense not yet but they didn't at this
time last year the defense is very good
are they actually give them a chance to
win most if not all their games that
they'll be in and be competitive I'm not
saying it on the table I think that
defense can give them a chance man looks
like Michigan was the season goes on
well I'll tell you Brandon Wimbush plays
against everybody else the way he played
against Michigan and then Notre Dame has
got a shot pretty much yeah you know the
one thing the defense problem is a
running quarterback and when Bush does
that now he needs to be a better passing
quarterback for them to be a more
complete team but I will say that
Michigan intrigues me I'm gonna be very
interested to see how they play as they
go through the games here over the next
month or so because then Shay Patterson
offensively throw the ball a little more
effectively can they become a down field
passing team can they be dynamic because
the defense is very very good so then
I'll continue to get better
then let me ask you
question Mike Tirico since you also have
some local knowledge there in Ann Arbor
is it everybody keeps asking me if this
could possibly be a hot seat year for
Jim Harbaugh always thinking no no you
know no okay so unless Jim wants it to
be a hot seat year right he wants to go
somewhere which I see I think he goes
way beyond it first off they've had ten
ten ten ten and eight wins
not all hopefully it's better than it
had been right but people looking to
compete in a national championship level
that's still definitely part of the
equation here you're playing in a
difficult division that's a part of the
store for that I think for Jim the story
becomes pretty simple where else is he
gonna go at this point that he'll have
it better and I don't think he's gonna
find a better life situation coaching
alma mater parents are living there all
that stuff rolled into one so I think
this is the best an area for Jimmy the
best place for Jim to be so I don't
think we can be looking to go anywhere
anytime soon Mike Tirico here on the
Rich Eisen show so then so I guess
you're hopping a flight from Indiana to
Connecticut hosting Sunday Night
Football
our poll question here is which team
needs it most you know a nice sports
talk radio poll question on a Friday
before a week two of an NFL season and
you know ask the poll question of Mike
Derick Chris Brockman yeah Mike five
teams who most need to win this week
looking at Dallas Atlanta the Giants
Saints Steelers I'm gonna say Dallas
because I think falling behind - Owen -
would be the biggest problem and also
how they look - I mean finds defensive
thing is gonna be good again after week
one what do we remember we don't know
I'm just guessing of what it's going to
be is it a blip is it a preparation
openers it's a season-long trend Alex
flowing - Owens to national TV Giants if
they do if they lose without any sign of
a passing game that could be effective
that's gonna be a problem no because
written and danced right now that
stories were told by a thousand people
you know who know football missing them
is obvious the impact is noticeable but
without that threat of a passing game
their offensive line which is not as
good as it was in the salad days of that
run game two years ago with Zeke and dak
they're not gonna have a chance to open
up any holes even if it is not effective
I'm it's not of the level that was there
a couple of years ago so that would be
the one I don't worry about New Orleans
scoring points Atlanta does concern me
losing their two best defensive players
in terms of the young heart beat core
their defense and Jones and veal that
worries me there I'd say of the team
Durant their Dallas would be the one a
toe into they would have me the most
worried I am so spot on lockstep with
you Mike Tirico it is not funny because
it has been it has been maybe three
calendar years since the Jones family as
general manager question has been front
and center in Dallas the thirteen and
three season wiped that whole whether
they should be general managers as well
as owners off the off this radar screen
because of that thirteen and three
season with attack and Zeke drafting and
then we get last year a lot of the nine
and seven of the team could be chalked
up to what was going on with Ezekiel
Elliott and the court system and the
suspension now if this Sunday Night
Football game with say qualm Barkley
showing up and showing out for the
Giants and Odell heavy pocketed and paid
and if the Giants beat the Cowboys in
that manner as you point out then all of
a sudden its front and center of what
the Joneses have done with their
opportunity to build with a quarterback
that they're paying cents on the dollar
compared to other teams it's out and
that's to deal with the league now I
mean it's a huge whether people want to
take shots of my pal group they're not
there the fact is that part of the story
with the Raiders I mean they were not in
a position where they are right now to
load up on multiple big contract guys
and you the derrick karr windows no
longer there
if Phillies in the same
why the Rams able to you know feel like
that's a fantasy team that you can't
beat because the guy always gets the
right pick of the green and the right
guys their roster you turn around it's
loaded all of a sudden because they're
on the good end of the golf deal and
that's the math of the current NFL as
the cap has risen the prices have risen
astronomically for the big stars with
what Aaron Rodgers makes where else is
the money allocated in Green Bay dude do
they have that second superstar player
you know those types of things play out
but I think the finances of the league
are I don't understand them very well I
may try the best I can but I think
they're underappreciated when you look
at maneuvering and deals and to your
point yeah there is a lot of money
resistant offensive line let's remember
to entry factors in here
there's no way or illness in this case
there's no way anybody could have known
right what the situation was going to be
with Travis Frederick correct that's not
a big loss that's a massive loss and
such a big loss and Oh Zack Martin and
Frederick those guys helped make this
entire thing go so I'm not ready to say
no shame on you in terms of management
cuz you guys failed I think it's more
all right you're in a bad spot can you
find somebody to plug in and fill that
gap but that's where having a team
that's strong in one spot can concern
you Mike there we go spread out as you
go through the year Mike Tirico here in
the Rich Eisen show sorry I reset at the
end of your comment I did not so have
you spoken to your buddy Gruden lately
oh I didn't speak to him this week I've
been in touch with them by text probably
I don't know probably two three times a
week all the way since before camp open
yes we say class means as you know with
moods and the guys on the set there when
we all work together if you don't have
one of those atmospheres where it works
well they're not just your coworkers
they become friends oh yeah
now John John's a friend for life
regardless of what happens so they would
stay in touch all the time you know I
got in and it's a perfect way to put it
like friends for life no doubt about it
and Gruden he's just a great dude
be around I mean just an all-timer in
terms of storytelling in good times and
whatever you know I mean you just want
to Fowler on before me Chris and I
haven't worked together in you know four
or five years we grab dinner in New York
City together just just a month or so
ago when he was in for the US Open I was
in for some preseason NFL I haven't done
games with Herbstreit in years but every
week we text and talk back and forth it
that is one of the joys of this job and
it simply you Suze your wife Albany
would we all say friends through this
whole process which is which is kind of
cool
it does take you to an interesting place
when you're watching games because
you're you know you care about your
friends at the same time you're trying
to watch the game you okay the Rams are
good here's why the Rams are good the
Raiders have work to do why do the
Raiders have work you're doing it so you
always have to especially when your
friends get back in coaching put some of
that aside and deal with the realities
of what's going on within their business
and with their job at that point I know
I'm n you know and certainly when it's
just amazing how quickly something
massive happened on Gruden's watch in
Oakland I mean how how do you think he
did grapple with Mack at all best you
might share with us we didn't talk too
much specifically about that because you
kind of know what the deal is or what
the scenario is for him is this plays
out John taught me a lot of things one
thing he taught me was fourth quarter
pass working jig so if there's any way
to get that thing to work out he would
have done it in a heartbeat he would
have loved to have done it I'm sure but
they've got to deal with their financial
realities and they've got to deal with
their football now is it gonna be the
best move for them my guess is no but I
don't know no we saw one game we have no
idea what the two first rounders are
going to be we have no idea is this
franchise winning now are they building
for Vegas what are they doing so it's
it's the 2018 way of doing sports in the
media you make an immediate bold
pronouncement this was the best or the
worst ever and then you don't come back
get back check on it you know it kind of
runs like our society people say to have
no respect checks that doesn't mean that
people aren't right saying this is a bad
deal we don't know we won't know for it
for a while I think they got the most
they could get out of it
I credit Chicago for roll the dice
because there's back into this too
you're talking about
okay the Cowboys and building their team
around Zeke Elliott back Prescott what
Chicago gonna look like without two ones
here going forward over the next couple
of years we get your Biscay in his prime
hopefully in years three four five six
and you're not adding those other pieces
hopefully for them they feel like when
they gotten back at a young point in his
career will equal anything to one's
could have that that's why we love
sports because there's a whole bunch of
rich throwing out there I know I do know
this
John John was throwing it back into
coaching and he hated Tuesday morning he
hated the loss but I can tell you behind
the scenes rich every time we walk out
of the stadium
he missed the guys who are the coaches
doing their wedding press conference and
even missed the misery of losing because
that makes the winning so much sweeter
so I'm sure he's still glad to be back
no matter what the result was week one
Mike miss talking to your you're the
best we'll chat soon thanks for calling
it here pal keep up the good work hi to
you guys in the studio love your family
man same you see me that's Mike Tirico
at Mike Tirico the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience